[Music]
Saudi Arabians call this place the edge
of the world this spectacular landscape
can be found on the outskirts of Riyadh
the capital city people like to come
here because it's a very quiet area very
fresh and clean air far away from the
city every time when I came here I have
the same feeling the feeling of the God
by 2030 the edge of the world will be
home to an entertainment complex two and
a half times the size of Disneyworld in
the past Saudi Arabia was not a holiday
destination for international leisure
tourists the country is governed by
strict Islamic laws women was cover up
in public gender segregation is common
and alcohol is forbidden this can be at
odds with what Western tourists look for
when booking a holiday but under the
leadership of Mohammed bin Salman the
young Crown Prince the country is
changing
tourism is at the heart of his plans to
revolutionize the kingdom he is plowing
billions of dollars from the country's
sovereign wealth fund into building a
new tourist resort in the red sea the
project will cover 50 islands and 34,000
square kilometers an area bigger than
Belgium there are separate plans for a
futuristic eco city and special economic
zone stretching into Jordan and Egypt
the princes ambitious plan aims to
attract 30 million visitors by 2030
double the current number
Rifat shisha hopes more tourists will
discover what the country has to offer
at his resort guests can enjoy dinner
and admire the form and grace of these
purebred Arabian horses this is pure
Arabian horse
this horse is purely from Saudi Arabia
and from this area Rafa usual guests are
visiting dignitaries businesspeople and
wealthy Saudi families but soon you
could be welcoming foreign leisure
tourists to
because of the growth of the tourism
business I'm targeting all nationalities
all the people and all the family the
crown prince wants to diversify the
economy which is heavily dependent on
oil hydrocarbons account for over 80
percent of the kingdom's government
revenues one way to diversify is to
entice more tourists the vast majority
of visitors at present are religious
pilgrims to Mecca 15 million people
visit the holy city each year the annual
Hajj is the biggest gathering of Muslims
in the world if some of them can be
tempted to extend their stay and visit
other sites that will boost tourism
[Music]
Saudis going on holiday abroad spend
around twenty five billion dollars
annually the Prince wants them to spend
more of that money at home such ideas
are inspired by neighboring to buy it is
now the third biggest tourism city in
the world attracting a global clientele
and contributing 20% to the country's
GDP they have relaxed many social rules
and permit alcohol in resorts you cannot
compare to buy in Saudi Arabia Dubai is
the city with one road when ten shopping
malls and 100 totals that's it in Saudi
Arabia we have the heritage Saudi Arabia
is the heart of Arab and Islamic world
is the hub connecting three continents
visiting Saudi Arabia is a unique
experience many Western tourists may be
put off by such restrictions it is
unclear how far Mohammed bin Salman will
be willing to relax social norms to
attract Western tourists the rest code
is part of the social environment here
in Saudi Arabia in terms of men and
females so Saudi Arabia try to emphasize
tourists and communicate with them
what's proper for them to wear when they
come and visit Saudi Arabia the crown
prince has a vision but investing
billions of dollars in luxury resorts is
a gamble that might not pay off Saudi
Arabia will have to find a balance in
appealing to religious tourists Saudis
and those from farther afield Saudi
Arabia is largely untouched by tourism
and is a mystery for many travelers that
alone is a reason to visit
you
[Music]